- Everybody that's successful
lays a blueprint out.
You laid a blueprint out.
I saw myself, honestly, as a model
when I first started.
- A model?
- You going to have bumps in the road.
You going to have things that happen
that make you have a hit come in.
I come from a happy place.
Even when my place was dark, I'm happy.
Jim Carrey, the comedian,
doesn't stand a chance against
Robin Williams, the comedian.
I think I'm sexy.
I tell my lady all the
time, "Babe, I'm sexy."
As a father, you want to teach
your kids certain things.
But I look back at my
life, George, you know,
I don't have a lot to teach.
- He's an American actor,
comedian, writer, and producer.
In 2015, Time Magazine named him
one of the Top 100 Most
Influential People in the World.
He currently stars as
himself in the lead role
in the Real Husbands of Hollywood.
He's Kevin Hart, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules of Success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonuses.
- Everybody that's successful
lays a blueprint out.
You laid a blueprint out.
You know, I could go down
a list, from comedians
to actors to entrepreneurs
to self-made moguls.
You look at Russell
Simmons, you look at Jay-Z.
You look at Tyler Perry, you look at Puff.
I mean, you're looking at people
that start off with a small vision.
And that vision manifested in
something beyond expectation.
So what I did was, from
the people around me,
my mentors, Eddie Murphy,
Chris Rock, Pryor--
- Who are all on the walls.
- [Kevin] All on the walls,
yeah, all on the walls.
- So you surround yourself with that.
- I surround myself
with a constant reminder
of who is great.
Constantly.
I come down the steps every
day, I look at Richard.
He was great.
I see Eddie, he was great.
I see Chris Rock, he was great.
It's a constant reminder.
What am I trying to achieve?
I want to be great.
So that motivates me.
So the thing that
separates me is my drive.
My drive is other people's success.
- Are you surprised by
your success at all?
- I don't want to say I am,
because then I'm going to
think I'm just doing something
for a lesser benefit.
You know, I think you'd
do anything to maximize
your potential, whatever
realm you put yourself in.
With entertainment, there's so many doors
that you can go through, I mean,
you're literally looking
at 15 to 20 doors...
- Yeah, but going back in your life,
would you ever see
yourself in this position?
This position now?
- I saw myself, honestly, as a model
when I first started.
- A model?
- Yeah.
- A runway model?
- Uh no, it was weird.
Kids' clothes, I was...
The point that I'm making is
I saw myself going in a direction
where I would be able
to make people smile.
And standup comedy is one thing I knew
that would be able to
put me in that position.
And standup comedy has taken me
into a place that, you know, is amazing.
Life is too short and I feel like everyone
needs to live, love, and laugh.
And understand like, you know,
you're constantly evolving.
Things are constantly changing,
things are constantly putting new,
putting people in position
where they can get better and do better.
We're doing a lot better
and you're going to
have bumps in the road,
you're going to have things that happen
and make you have a
hiccup and you question,
"are we doing better?"
But that's life. That's
the course of life.
But, you know, I'm a positive person,
I'm a realistic and positive person
so I see where we are,
I'm happy where we are,
and I know where we can be
five or 10 years from now
and continue to get better and grow.
For me, you know what, I
believe hard work pays off.
You know, when you say it's been my year
and it's my time, you
know, Hollywood has a way
of making everything seem
like overnight success.
"Oh my god, where did this guy come from?"
"Oh, this kid, who is he, look!"
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- "He's a massive star!"
I'm 18 years in the business, you know?
- You put in your 10,000 hours.
- I put in my time!
You know, I got dues that've
been paid and paid again
and paid one more time after that.
I stayed true to my dreams.
And by doing that,
eventually they came true.
- A lot of comedians go on stage,
and they're hiding who they are.
A lot of comedians come from a dark place.
- [Kevin] They do.
- You let it all out there.
- I come from a heavy place.
Even when my place was dark, I'm happy.
I'm happy simply because I
have no reason to be angry.
Life is too short to be angry,
so the things that I do feel
a certain type of way about,
that I may get upset about,
I let it out, I get out onstage
and I allow other people
to judge and laugh at it.
The reason why they're laughing is
because I'm honest.
I think when people can
relate to that honesty...
- [Woman] The truth is
always the funniest.
- It is the funniest!
I don't care what happens to you,
there is a positive and a negative
in everything that happens to you.
And if you think about it,
after you're done being negative,
I guarantee you'll laugh.
I don't care how bad, how severe
it is, after it's happened,
when you really breakdown what happened...
- [Man] The human condition!
- Oh my goodness, you're going to laugh.
- [Woman] It takes some time sometimes.
- Well, if you, give it a couple hours.
- A couple hours!
- If you ask any comedian
that has a real
understanding and knowledge
of standup comedy, then
people will probably say
Dave Chapelle is the best pound for pound.
- [Man] Okay.
- And that's including everybody.
You know, this is one of
the most creative guys
on the planet.
And when it comes to breaking down a joke,
and making a joke a joke
within a joke within a joke,
Dave Chapelle does like nobody else.
It's a science.
True story: me and Chris
Rock watched Dave Chapelle
at the Comedy Cellar, me and
Chris Rock went up already.
You know, me and Chris Rock.
I called Chris and said, "Chris come down,
"I'm working on some material,
I want you to look at it."
Chris said "alright me
too, I'm coming down."
He said, "I'll watch you, you watch me,
"let's punch each other up."
Watch, I'll watch Chris
after, you watch me,
we're talking about our sets,
Dave Chapelle comes in randomly,
Dave Chapelle goes up.
Me and Chris watch Dave
Chapelle, swear to god,
we took our material, balled it up.
(all laughing)
And was like, what the
(beep) are we talking about?
We were so pissed off with
our level of thinking,
and Dave Chapelle, he was (beep) around!
"Ah, (beep), man! (Beep)."
But he's that good.
Now Louis C. K. On the other hand,
is polished as they come.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Louis C. K. is a bad boy man.
Like, Louis C. K. Will
take your common premise
and that premise becomes a 10 minute bit
and that bit becomes a story and an arc
within the whole set that he's doing
and when you look at it,
at the end of the set,
what he's bringing on
is, you know who he is.
That's a great comedian.
When you walk away and
you know that guy's life,
but not in a way that
where you studied it,
but in a way where you related to it,
and he painted such a perfect picture
that all you did was go,
"oh my god, I get it!"
I know that Louis C. K. is divorced,
I know Louis C. K. has two daughters,
I know that one of his
daughters is his favorite,
I know that the other little girl,
he likes her but she's an asshole.
I know this because of,
not only his material,
but he says it in a way that
you can see he's authentic.
It's not, this isn't forced comedy.
And I think that's the brilliance
behind those comedians.
Robin Williams! Oh man, dope. Dope.
Jim Carey! (beep)
- [Man] Wow! Damn! Of all people!
- (beep) Alright, we got to be honest.
We got to be honest.
(murmurs of agreement)
Alright, um, Jim Carey the comedian
doesn't stand a chance against
Robin Williams the comedian.
I think it's better to
break these two down,
for comedic acting.
Because Robin Williams, as a comedian,
when you understand, if you
really, really are educated,
Robin Williams is one of
the best impressionists
to ever do it, and to really like,
when I say dive into an impression,
Robin Williams became the
people that he impersonated.
Like he, he literally set the arc
for so many other people behind him,
to start to break it down and start
and get all the little nuances,
because from all of the body posture,
to the facial, to the mannerism,
Robin Williams, pound for
pound, was the best at it.
When it comes to comedic
acting, goddammit man,
Jim Carey, you know, if you don't want
to give him his respect, that's on you.
I will, Jim Carey, when it
comes to physical comedy,
I don't think nobody touches Jim Carey
when it comes to physical comedy.
I think Robin Williams
is amazing at adapting
to whatever character he
chooses to be in the film,
but Jim Carey sacrifices
his body for a take.
Jim Carey throws himself against a wall,
if you look at Me, Myself, and Irene,
the scene where he fought
himself and grabbed his neck,
and threw himself off the cliff
and got up and jabbed,
and had the conversation
between the two guys,
Jim Carey set the tone
for other people to do it.
In Get Hard, where I'm trying to do
the prison yard scene and
I'm imitating the people,
that's a reflection of Jim Carey
and what Jim Carey's shown.
- [All] Hmmm.
- And when you go look at Ace
Ventura and The Pet Detective,
and from the silliness of Jim
Carey talking with his butt,
that stuff now, if you
look, if you look at it
and you think, "comedy, man."
That stuff sticks in people's heads!
Jim Carey acting like he was
birthed out the elephant's butt
and playing like the baby stuff,
he is a different level of thinking.
And he just went dark for a minute
and went into serious roles,
but I don't think
anybody touches Jim Carey
in that realm, and you know,
from what I do and what I attempt to do,
I'm attempting things and creating nuances
from the things that
I've seen from the greats
and Jim Carey's one of those greats.
Shoutout to Robin Williams,
I can't do impressions, but if I could,
I would definitely try to do them
the way you did, brother,
because nobody does it
better, rest in peace.
I'm beyond confident.
I'm not cocky, I'm so confident.
I'm confident in who I am,
I'm confident in the person that I am,
I think I'm sexy.
I tell my lady all the
time, "babe, I'm sexy."
I just got two ugly toes, that's it.
That's my thing.
I just, I love me!
- You're sexy with your socks on.
- Yeah, yes, I don't take my socks off.
I don't take them off,
but I wear good socks!
That's the plus.
I just don't believe, I
don't believe in change,
I don't believe in doing things
to manufacture my body to appeal
to what I think people might like.
This is, this is it!
This is what I was given.
This is my playing cards.
If we was playing poker, I
got to make this hand work.
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- This is it for me.
And this is what I'm going to ride out.
So how do you not embrace
it? You get one life.
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- One!
You get one life. I'm
going to embrace myself.
- Do you run out of energy,
emotionally or physically?
- [Woman] This is him not sleeping!
- This is me on no sleep right now.
I don't, I can't express
how happy of a person
I am, I can't express how inspiring
and I guess you can say motivating my life
and the people around me are.
I think there's a fine line,
you don't ever want to offend people,
you don't ever want to
stir up any trouble.
And so at the end of the day,
if you keep it self-evolved
you're fine, you know?
The key in the art that
I learned is basically
to do these things, but to
do it in such a cool way
that people laugh but they go,
"yo, even though he's saying the things
"that he's saying, the way
he's saying it is funny.
"The way he's saying it,
the way he goes about it.
"To get his point across
is very unique and funny."
And that's the trick to being universal
and making everybody laugh.
- What can you pass along to your kids
that they would understand?
- Well, you know what George,
it's funny you say that,
because I've been having a hard time
figuring out the type of life lessons
that I'm trying to hand my kids, you know?
Basically, as a father you want to
teach your kids certain things,
but I look back at my life, George,
you know, I don't have a lot to teach!
(laughter)
Like, here's another thing, like okay,
and this is me being like
very honest, you guys.
My daughter is a little princess,
beautiful, she's spoiled.
So you know, I'm one way with her,
but my son, I'm like, I live in L.A.,
I'm in the valley, you know,
my son ain't around tough kids,
my main thing is teaching
my son how to fight.
- [George] How old is he?
- My son's three.
(laughter)
You don't see what goes on
in these daycares, alright!
It's crazy!
I caught a little boy putting
pens to my son's mouth
that's when I had enough!
I said, I'm going to teach
my son how to defend himself.
Now, the only problem I'm having,
my son, my son thinks he's
Spiderman, George, for real.
Right? I'm not joking.
Like when we play, he webbed me, he like.
But because I'm his dad, when he does it,
I got to act like I'm caught.
I'm like "oh no, let me out. Let me out!"
So, but it's playing!
So let me tell you why this
is bad, I'm not joking,
so I go to pick him up for school, right?
And this little boy is
hitting my son in the head
with a truck, right?
My son on the floor doing this: fwpt!
He don't, he trying to web him!
I yelled, I got so mad.
I said, "boy, you get ya ass
up, you're not Spiderman, man!"
"You're not Spiderman!"
He tried to get me.
While I was talking, but I had to play,
I was like, "okay, let
me out, let Dad out."
(laughter)
You all laugh, but I'm
being so serious, man.
My household, (beep) my son is in trouble
if I don't save him!
He really thinks he's Spiderman, George.
Don't judge, don't judge my son, okay?
(laughter)
Don't judge my son!
I love my son.
(cheering)
I'll have my son come here
and web this whole audience.
Right now. My son'll web all of you.
And you all better act like
you're caught in the net.
- Kevin, I want you to
pretend like you're Dwayne.
- Okay.
- In high school, and Dwayne,
you're Kevin in high school.
And answer just a few questions, so um...
- I'm Kevin Hart in high
school right now, 17 years old.
- And I'm DJ.
- There you go.
What would you like to
be when you grow up?
(laughter)
- If I could be a fireman,
that would be cool.
- Dude, that's me.
- I would love to be a fireman.
Are you going to eat that puddin'?
(laughter)
- Going to eat the puddin'!
- Dwayne? You can come
back with something strong?
- Yeah, okay.
I'm Kevin Hart, right.
Right, in high school.
Hey, hey, hey! Hey e'rbody hey!
Hey gurl!
No? She ain't hear me, she ain't hear me.
(laughter)
Hey what's up my (censored),
no? No? He ain't see me.
C'mon! Aw (censored). C'mon.
Hey Ms. Johnson! I'm going
to do good on that test. Yes.
Yes.
- I'm sorry, I think there's two flies
having sex behind you.
Look at the, I'm very
serious, look how big that is,
that's two flies, you see that?
Wow I'm sorry, that's
pretty amazing to me.
Never seen anything like, oh! (Beep)
Jesus Christ!
As the little guy, the
strategy for fighting
is first of all, I don't
people to fight, man,
you know, I'm a guy that
promotes positivity.
So I love love, but if
you are going to fight,
and you small, you bite!
- [Man] You bite! Really?
- You bite, man.
You, you go low and bite!
Go for, go for either a
calf, or the achilles tendon!
That's what you bite!
- [Man] Really?
- Everybody knows that,
it'll take your opponent out,
nobody can withstand a bite
on the achilles tendon.
You going to do this instantly,
that person goes down,
you get the best of them, you won!
Everybody knows that.
- [Man] Did you have a lot of trouble?
Being a short guy and trying to bite...
- Yeah, I'm a known killer, man.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because
Symari Alexander asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What change you're going to make now
after watching this video.
Leave it in the comments,
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
- How's everybody doing?
This is a beautiful crowd, man,
I love big crowds, just to
get something off my chest
before I even start.
Everything I say up here
tonight is a joke, okay?
It is nothing else, I don't
want nobody taking any
of this stuff too serious,
I don't need nobody
coming up to me after the show,
talking about who's the
funny one now, all that.
(laughter)
If there's anyone who's ready
to fight and stuff like that,
I'm a bitch and I will let it be known.
We're on the same page
now, I don't like to fight,
I've been robbed a lot, I'm traumatized,
because a lot of us haven't
been on the same page.
On top of all that, I don't
need you all fighting me.
It's getting now, where it's mental,
I get scared real fast.
I'm going to ask this group right here,
don't try to make no sudden
movements right there.
Everybody put your hands on the tables
so I know you doin' at all times.
That's my time, that's my show.
My name's Kevin, I will walk right off.
If it was different, man, I'm serious,
it would've been different
if I was getting robbed
by big people, people that
should be robbing people,
you know, you're a big guy.
If you rob me I'm going
to have to accept it,
you know what, you're bigger, take it.
I'm letting you know.
But it's not going down like that.
I'm getting robbed by women,
groups of kids running up on my now,
I got robbed by a real strong midget,
he didn't even have a gun.
He just kept headbutting me,
he just kept on headbutting me.
I finally just said, "sir,
that's enough, mister midget."
And I fell and he took off running.
You know you real scared if
you call a midget mister.
That's how you know.
I was like, that's enough.
I think the worst time
was when I got robbed
by a cross-eyed man, that took the cake.
Let me tell you all why a man robbed me.
He got upset with me because I didn't know
that he was robbing me.
He was cross-eyed, what the
hell was I supposed to say?
He just came up yelling, "give it up!"
(laughter)
Are you robbing me,
what are you talkin'...
"Stop playing with me and don't move,
"give it up!" (laughter)
"I have not moved since
I been standing here."
Now, Home, give it to
him, I think he's serious.
"I was talking to you!"
I said, "you wait a minute, alright?
"I thought you was talkin' to him.
"If you talkin' to me
you need to look at him,
"If you talking to me."
"I got to figure this out."
I was so scared, you all.
I wouldn't lie.
You don't realize I run a whole lot.
Did you know it's rude to run
if the person next to
you is getting robbed?
Did you know that?
Let's say it's me and you together,
somebody run up on us, to rob us.
If I run from the situation, I'm a bitch.
That right.
And me personally, I
don't agree with this.
In any situation, when I had to run
on certain friends of mine.
If there's a gun, I'm a have
to say, to hell with them.
You know why?
Because they saw a gun
just like I saw a gun.
That means they chose
to stay at that time!
I told them to run and
then I got out of there.
And for some reason, until this day,
my girl does not understand
why I run on her.
Listen, I'm telling you all something.
When they started coming, I said "go!"
And she said "stay!"
And that's my girl.
I never seen us like that in my life.
And she got upset with
me because she thought
I was, y'know, I was just
standing and just watching
what was going on, where they was going,
but that wasn't the case
and by the time I got away,
I remembered she had the key to the car.
When I turned around they was
still hitting her and stuff
so I was like, "I'm going
to wait till they finish."
Ain't no sense in both of us
getting our asses ripped up.
That would be real selfish
of her, wouldn't it?
Somebody has to drive home.
That's how I look at it.
Somebody has to get us home.
That's all I had to say.
You know, females, you just don't realize,
men, people are too crazy to
be fighting everybody, man.
People are losing they minds now,
to be fighting everybody.
I'm sorry, I am not a hostile person.
I'm friendly and I'll admit it.
I don't like to fight, I'm a friend.
I'm your friend, alright!
Don't you take nothing out on me.
You know where I was when I saw some
of the craziest people I seen rob,
I was on a train.
I swear to you all,
I never seen this many
crazy people in my life.
Have you ever sat next
to someone on a train
that's asleep for the whole train ride.
And when their stop come up
they just pop the hell up
and get up and walk off the train?
Don't nobody touch them or nothing!
And you be sitting next to them,
you like, "who touched them!
"I don't believe it, he got right up!"
Old people, they really get me mad,
because they get upset with you,
when you don't want to give
up your seat, you know.
No, to hell with you, I'm tired too.
When you see them, do what I do,
act like you're asleep.
Just look like this.
"I can't believe this,
I can't believe this,
"she comin' back, she comin' back!
"Go back to sleep."
Don't give up your seat, I don't.
But you know what I love, that pervert guy
that stands like this in the center?
And then when the bus get real crowded
and he got to grind on everybody's
butt to get to the back?
"Excuse me baby, watch out,
I'm going to get to the back,
"stay right there, I'm just
trying to get to the back,
"don't move, I'm just trying to get,
"just stay right there, I'm
almost there baby, don't move
"I can't believe they sat you up front,
"oh, goodness."
He is a professional grinder, be careful.
He do that for a living.
And you know, that's not
the only thing that's crazy.
Me myself, I think dirty
people might be some
of the craziest people I've been to.
Because you have to be some kind of crazy
or mental person just as a side
at some point of your life to be dirty.
That's a crazy decision.
How does something like that go down?
Do you just wake up one morning mad?
"I ain't washing my ass no more!"
And then go back to sleep, that's it.
Because that's not something
you can just forget to do.
You can't keep saying "I
forgot to wash my ass again!"
That's good for the first couple days,
but three weeks later you
still saying the same thing,
and your friends, they going
to start to question you.
"This been goin' on for three weeks!"
Everybody wants a tattoo now, you know.
Everybody needs a tattoo.
I have no problem with tattoos,
I feel if you're going to get a tattoo,
get something that you know what it says.
Everybody wants a Chinese tattoo now.
For what? You don't know
what it really says!
You walking around thinking
you got "black power"
or something on your head.
Turns out you go into a Chinese store,
you got "salt, pepper, ketchup"
written across your face.
And you don't know the
Hongs start laughing.
"Look at this, 'salt, pepper,
ketchup!' Right there!"
"No, this says 'black power.'"
"No sir, no sir, 'salt, pepper, ketcup!'
"Across your face."
Be careful.
Do things that we know we're doing.
You know what's funny in the gym though,
you all see those people in
the gym that are too strong?
You all see somebody in
the gym that's too strong?
They got too many muscles?
I saw this one guy, he
had too many muscles!
I had to tell him, I said, "that's enough!
"Goddamn, don't you have nothing else?
"Where you going to put that muscle? Huh?"
And he talk something like,
"oh I got this soft spot behind my ear,
"do me a favor and put 345 pounds
"on the back of my neck so I can go ahead
"and lift that up."
And I was going to get it,
and I looked at him in the face,
that was the midget that had robbed me!
Hey, you all been a great crowd,
my name is Kevin Hart, I
hope you enjoyed the show.